[Music]
welcome to my ultimate cookery course
packed with quick cooking tips know-how
and 100 recipes to take your life on
okay get ready for my ultimate guide to
bacon
[Music]
whether it's breads cakes tarts pies or
pastries bacon is one of the most
seductive skills in the kitchen
it fills the house with fantastic aromas
and puts irresistible food on the table
now i'm gonna put you on the road to
bacon nirvana starting with an easy
bread packed with big gutsy flavors
olive tomato and rosemary for catcher
i absolutely love bacon bread there's
something
really satisfying about doing it and
this focaccia recipe is very hands-on
but the end result
is something really really tasty
first off start with the dough
tip 500 grams of strong bread flour into
a mixing bowl and add 20 grams of
semolina
that gives the vacation it's sort of
rustic charm
now there's one thing for catcher needs
it's really good seasoning you can't
season bread after it's baked so it's
got to go in right at the very beginning
sprinkling 15 grams of dried yeast
take some warm water
and then 50 mils of olive oil top of
that water
that gives it this really nice silky
rich texture
make a little well
mix up that yeast water
and oil in
start off with your fingers keep your
fingers nice and open it's like a little
sort of whisk going in there i'm looking
for a really nice sort of relaxed
dough
now that's just starting to come
together touch more water with oil in
there give a little swirl
and then again
the secret is to sort of knead it gently
don't overwork it
it's a sort of
easy bread to make a nice one to start
off with when you're making bread for
the first time
basically kneading means just knit it
together
just hanging
lightly flour
your board
and let's just knead that for catcher
into a nice smooth dough
make sure you don't over add
too much flour otherwise it sort of
dries out the dough
something quite
magical about making bread you can
switch off
and lose yourself
my first job for a three-mission style
establishment was a baker i was 22 years
of age and to start at midnight i was
under such a tight schedule
one o'clock white bread then two o'clock
brown bread
three o'clock sourdough four o'clock
cheese bread
five o'clock proof bake
six o'clock crack them open and taste it
was amazing
beautiful yeah
looks stunning it hasn't even risen yet
leave your dough to rise in a warm place
until it's doubled in size we call this
proving
[Music]
that
beautiful a lot of chefs sort of need it
for the second time but i'm looking for
a really nice light aerated for catcher
take your tray
a touch of olive oil in there season it
at the bottom really important
that's the exciting thing about focaccia
you've got that really nice sort of
salty top
and salty bottom
and just with a touch of olive oil
on your hands
gently push that in and almost massage
it into the corners it's possible to put
sort of olives and tomatoes and garlic
through the dough but it never really
allows the dough to sort of aerate
properly when you put so much
ingredients in
i'm gonna stick mine on top use your
finger and sort of just push them in
salt on top
some pepper on top as well
i want some nice
fresh amazing rosemary just hold the
stalk and just pull off
and then just sprinkle down generous in
the rosemary
really important to have that nice
fragrance on top of the fuckacha
finish it off before it goes in
with a little drizzle of olive oil
so it
almost sinks in those little pockets of
flavor olive tomato rosemary and olive
oil
into the
oven bake your focaccia at 200 degrees
for 30 to 35 minutes
[Music]
smells
delicious beautiful
[Music]
you can hear how crispy that is
you can't beat a nice warm fresh slice
of home-cooked focaccia it's rustic
charming and it's the perfect way
to start bacon making homemade for
catcher
it's so addictive
getting to grips with bacon is just a
matter of confidence and once you've
grasped the basics then the
possibilities are limitless
here are three more of my favorite super
simple bread recipes to get you going
kicking off with my simple soda bread
first up measure out your dry
ingredients
plain flour
wholemeal flour
salt
caster sugar
[Music]
and bicarbonate of soda
[Music]
mix
get 450 ml of buttermilk pour most of it
in and combined
buttermilk has a wonderful subtle sour
note that gives this bread a deliciously
different taste you can get it in most
of the big supermarkets
if your dough is a bit stiff add the
rest of your buttermilk
flour your board
gently knead the mixture for about 30
seconds until it's all combined
dust your baking tray
place your dough in the center
and score a deep cross with a knife to
get a perfect crust
then simply bake in a preheated oven for
30 to 35 minutes
amazingly easy absolutely delicious and
foolproof
hot crusty homemade soda bread whenever
you want
my next no sweat bread recipe is even
faster to make
quick flatbreads with lemon thyme and
ricotta
for the dough mix first slice a leek
lengthwise and chop
soda in a pan with olive oil and butter
till tender
season
next combine flour with a pinch of
seasoning
and olive oil
and mix in your cooked leeks
bring the dough together in a bowl with
a drop of warm water
cover and rest for 20 minutes
allowing the dough mixture to relax
means the resulting bread will be nice
and soft
then dust the dough with flour
mold into a sausage shape
slice it into rounds
[Music]
and flatten with a rolling pin
then simply fry in a hot dry pan
[Music]
when golden and crisp on each side
remove for a simple supper serve with a
cottage cheese
lemon zest
and fresh thyme
so simple so fast and so versatile
flatbreads to die for
next how to make one of the world's most
popular bread-based foods fast
mozzarella and rosemary pizza
[Music]
for the pizza dough add yeast to warm
water
in a tablespoon of sugar
and leave to one side
in a separate bowl add sieve flour
make a well and add your olive oil and
yeast mixture
get your hands right in to bring it
together
then knead for about 10 minutes on a
floured surface
until even and smooth
put back into the bowl
cover and leave in a warm place to prove
once it's roughly doubled in size
knock any excess air out
place back on your surface
divide your dough into four balls
and simply flatten
[Music]
add olive oil to a hot pan and put in
the pizza dough
pizza is usually cooked in a seriously
hot oven but this pan cook method works
brilliantly
as the dough starts to bubble and the
base turns golden spoon over tomato
passata which is sift tomatoes
and tear in chunks of mozzarella
then simply transfer to a hot grill
until golden and bubbly
finished with fresh rosemary
i love this classic combination but you
can easily adapt it and add your own
favorite topping for a perfect pizza in
minutes
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stake your life on
right now it's all about bacon i'm going
to show you how to make a sponge cake
smothered in luxury so nice to finish
something sweet on top but first my
guide to getting the best ingredients
for your money
whether i'm doing a simple sponge cake
or make an elaborate tart i want my
bacon to be the best it can be so i
always start with the best ingredients i
can find
knowledge is crucial the more you know
personally about where your ingredients
are from and how they produce the better
[Applause]
[Music]
flour
to get the low down on one of the key
ingredients to brilliant baking it
always pays to ask an expert and if
there's one man who can really rise to
the occasion it's professional miller
mark abel
doing a job like this means that you end
up thinking and living a flower if
that's obsession i'm obsessed
[Music]
at his mill which has stood in norfolk
since 1835 mark uses traditional stones
to grind his flower so he really knows
his stuff
[Music]
what actually comes
off the field is something like this
still husked still needs to be processed
before we can actually mill it we then
clean down to something like this
which is ready to be milled
[Music]
all this is a great big machine which
means you don't have to do it by hand
rather than try and improve its
performance by adding additional
chemicals
what we're trying to do is mill it in
the best way to get that performance
from it
[Music]
if you can put a seed in between stones
you can make flour out of it uh it's
that simple barley was what was
traditionally used to make bread for
people to live off
oats can be used as well and of course
good old spelt the great grandmother of
modern wheats which has the most
fantastic flavor and is
because of its primitive nature the
proteins in it are simpler so a lot of
people can eat that they can't eat
modern weight
keep your eyes on the shelves look and
see what is there and if something
strikes you as being potentially
interesting then get it and try it mix
your own blend your own together so that
you can get the flavour that you want
with the performance that you want
[Music]
mark's right different flowers
performance tastes wildly different and
so they're well worth trying out here's
my quick guide to some of the flowers i
like using
strong flour is one to choose for
standard bread making the higher the
protein content the crust your loaf will
be
the flour hailing from italy double zero
it's super finely milled and perfect for
pasta i like to use it for pizzas too
because it produces a nice crispy crust
like the one on my mozzarella and
rosemary version
rye flour will give you really dense
fruity flavored bread fruit cakes or
scones if it's too heavy for you just
mix it with standard wheat flour
and when you are baking remember that
self-raising flour is just plain flour
with raisin asians added so if you run
out you can add baking powder and salt
to your plain flour and get baking
[Music]
that's the real stuff that's it fresh
flour straight out the mill is so
superior in flavor and performance that
is only when you come to use it you
realize what the difference is
if you're going to experiment with
ingredients in baking you still need to
follow some basic rules to make sure
things turn out brilliantly every time
then whether you're a master baker or
you're just starting out you can pimp up
the classics whether it's a victoria
sponge or a fruit scone
and that's the lesson perfectly
illustrated by my next recipe sponge
with fresh ginger
bacon is part chemistry
part imagination but you've got to rely
on the rules for great results it's the
only time you'll see me reaching for the
scales
first off eggs sugar butter and when i
say weigh out the ingredients it does
literally mean way out to the final gram
175
now 175 grams
of sugar
that's 350 grams in total cream the
butter and the sugar
to get a delicious light sponge start
carefully on slow speed
[Music]
only speed up as the butter and sugar
really start to cream together
keep that really nice and light you can
see how it's changed color so important
at the beginning
eggs in
give a little whisk
adding one egg at a time stops the mix
from separating
second again
third one in
[Music]
that's what we're looking for a really
nice sort of light airaidy texture
now gonna flavor the sponge
a little teaspoon of vanilla extract
that perfumes the mix
one teaspoon of baking powder that gives
lightness 175 grams of flour
and we're gonna sieve it a to get rid of
any lumps and b to keep it really nice
and fine
175.
we're not gonna beat that out we're just
gonna lightly fold that in now
what i'm looking for is a really nice
loose dough
that's looking a little bit too firm so
just a little splash of milk
a couple of tablespoons
that relaxes the mixture down
helps create that nice almost dropping
consistency
that's what i want
just starting to drop
take a non-stick loose bottom cake tin
grease it with butter then coat it with
flour to avoid the sponge sticking
just give that a little shake
make sure you get all the rim
now just get the back of the spatula
make sure you've got no peaks on my
sponge
to make sure the sponge bakes nice and
evenly tap the tin a few times to knock
out any air pockets that might have
formed in the mixture
now into the oven bake for 30 to 35
minutes at 180 degrees
as that's cooking prepare the ginger
cream for the center
300ml of cream give that a nice whisk
whisking cream by hand gives you so much
more control and it's so easy to over
whip cream i want that nice light ginger
cream in the center i don't want it
grainy nothing worse when cream starts
to separate
now let's get into that three-quarter
stage
little stiff peaks
stop that for two minutes fresh ginger
now get a really nice large slice of
ginger
smells incredible
it's so fragrant eating ginger is like
sort of peeling a potato
just take out all those little dark
spots
now get your grater
you haven't got a grater you can chop
the ginger really finely
have gone almost like a puree of ginger
going through but the juice as well
take your knife
and just scrape all that
taste
incredible
it's fragrant
and it's not sweet it's got a really
nice taste set that in the fridge
[Music]
smells incredible
run a knife around the outside to ensure
the cake doesn't stick to the tin before
turning it out
now get your hands under push up
and out
while your cake cools i'm gonna do like
a really nice sweet chocolate coating
pour 300 mils of double cream into a
saucepan add two tablespoons of golden
syrup to make the top nice and glossy
then whisk
chop this up really thinly
so as it melts
quickly
50 grams of butter that's gonna give the
chocolate a really nice shine
ball your cream and
mix it in
give that a really good stir
as the chocolate the butter melts it
thickens like how shiny that is
so nice to finish something sweet on top
topping done time to build your sponge
cake
look at the halfway mark there
and just gently
slice
and really take your time all the way
through
lift
that's delicious
that nice big dollop in the middle don't
be stingy don't be tight with a cream
another dollop on top spread that
very carefully
lift the lid and just sit there on top
that's why i start off with a little
extra cream in there so when i squash it
down the cream just pushes out to the
side
i'm not finished
pour the luxurious chocolate topping
over the sponge
be generous and make sure the cake is
coated thoroughly to give it a gorgeous
finish
get the bottom of the ladle and
spread whoa
one more
[Music]
wow
you've got to know when to say stop
and something looks that delicious
i just want to dive in there
[Music]
next five more my 100 tips to help you
cook better and of course these are all
about bacon
kicking off with how to whip cream
whipping cream now the important part
here is whipping the cream to a
three-quarter stage if we over whip it
it will split so be very careful
double cream in
now when we whisk things we whisk it in
the shape of a figure of eight and if
you spin the bowl as you whip the cream
you get to release it from the bottom so
it whips evenly
whisk whisk whisk and it should just sit
inside the whisk and start to sort of
fall out just
perfect
three-quarter stage double cream
done
room temperature cream whips much faster
than cold so you'll need to take your
cream out of the fridge 30 minutes
before you want to whip it unless of
course you want to work on your biceps
a great tip to prevent milk and cream
from boiling over in a saucepan is to
simply lay a wooden spoon across the top
the cream bubbles will rise up and hit
the wooden handle and then fall back
into the pan instead of bubbling over
sticky stuff like trinkle and golden
syrup can be a real mess to measure out
my tip is to rub the spoon with a
neutral oil like rave seed and any
sticky ingredients will slide straight
off
[Music]
and my tip for greasing cake tins is to
keep old butter wrappers on hand and use
them to crease when needed
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course packed
with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stay your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details go on get cooking
okay this time i'm gonna help you
achieve better bacon
the great thing about pastry is if you
follow the basic rules the possibilities
are endless whether it's simple short
crust or flaky filo
you just need a bit of practice to get
it right
my first recipe uses lovely buttery
shortcuts pastry to make a dish that's
as delicious as it is simple leek and
pancetta quiche
shortcuts pastry is one of the staples
of the kitchen
it is so versatile but the good news is
it's one of the easiest pastries to make
trust me when you crack it it can make a
real difference to your cooking
take a sieve
when you think of short crust pastry
it's sort of
semi-flaky but it's rich buttery
start by sipping 200 grams of plain
flour into a mixing bowl
large pinch
of salt
200 grams of unsalted butter
bring the butter up to room temperature
if you let the butter become too soft
then the flour so it doesn't absorb it
in with your fingers rub together first
now the secret is grab big handfuls and
squeeze the butter
into the flour
so look what's happened literally in 30
seconds i've got that nice
crumbly texture
now a couple of tablespoons
of water nothing worse when the pastry
is so wet you can't bring it together it
needs to shape like a nice rich cookie
dough it's just a touch too dry
so
one more
tablespoon of water
[Music]
and there you go it's coming nicely
now
that's what i want
a nice sort of firm ball of pastry
onto the board
i'm gonna use these
one of the strongest parts of the body
pull towards you
and push back down use
those wrists to really
knead it
together
so just that nice sort of smooth texture
now
wrap it in clin film
set there in the fridge for 20 minutes
really important that you let the
shortcuts pastry relax
[Music]
now to make the quiche you can use just
an ordinary flan dish but i love making
them in many frying pans which give them
an extra rustic charm
brush with oil to stop the pastry from
sticking
once the pastry is at room temperature
roll it out to a nice even thickness
place it in the center of your little
pan
turn it in don't use your fingers
because what we don't want is any holes
in this just get a little bit of
dough because that sort of acts like a
little sort of mallet
flattens it out nicely
i'm building a sort of
extra lip because that way i can get the
filling it's absolute maximum levels
we're going to cook them blind first
to blind bake simply means to pre-cook
your pastry before adding the filling
this ensures you'll have a fantastic
crisp pastry
add a sheet of foil or baking paper and
weigh it down
you can use rice pulses or ceramic
baking stones
just make sure you keep them for the
next time
in the oven 200 degrees for 10 minutes
now for the filling
i'm gonna do a classic quiche bacon and
leeks this is a amazing cured pancetta
pancetta is an italian cured meat made
from belly pork seasoning with things
like juniper nutmeg fennel a great
substitute is unsmoked bacon
as the manchetta gets lovely and crispy
finely slice leeks and add
oh
leeks and bacon nice
really important to cook those leeks
down
it's exactly what i want those leeks are
almost sort of caramelized slightly
crispy the flavor is amazing and just
drain them off so any excess fat gets
drained
a couple of tablespoons of cream
it gives it
a really nice richness
i want two-thirds garnish i.e bacon and
leeks in my quiche and one-third of the
savory custard a touch of salt
touch a pepper
and i grate some gruyere cheese
that makes a really nice sort of creamy
less of an eggy quiche take my amazing
crispy pancetta and leeks in
give that a good mix
needs one more little thing some
freshness
flat
leaf parsley
incredible
really important just to taste
the mixture
with the quiche filling ready next
finish off the pastry
[Music]
remove the fall and weight and return to
the oven to get it lovely and golden all
over
[Music]
now
when we fill them give that a really
good mix up
[Music]
beautiful
grate over some more cheese which will
bubble up and melt beautifully and then
into the oven
bake your quiche for 15 to 20 minutes
[Music]
incredible
it's got that nice sort of cheese and
toast smell from the top it's sort of
baked but the secret of any good quiche
is in the short crust because that's the
hero
there are lots of different types of
pastry so to help you put you on the
road to pace your perfection
here are three of my simple pastel
recipes that you can easily cook at home
first up my indulgent chocolate tarts
[Music]
first combine softened butter and sugar
and cream until soft
[Music]
break in an egg and mix well
next fold in the flour
[Music]
pour the mixture onto a floured surface
and simply knead it lightly till it's
well combined
then shape into a disc
and chill
then simply roll out your pastry until
it's about a quarter of a centimetre
thick
cut into small discs then gently press
into lightly greased loose bottom mini
tart tins
and prick the bottom to prevent the
pastry from bubbling
rest in the fridge this ensures that
when the pastry bakes it will turn out
nice and soft
then bake it till golden as they cool
make the gorgeous silky chocolate
filling
place a mixing bowl over a pan of gently
boiling water this is known as a
bain-marie
then add double cream
butter
and plain chocolate
then stir until it melts and it is
glossy and smooth
then pour it into the crisp and golden
pastry cases
and simply tap to level and chill until
set
so easy so indulgent and so delicious
eat them with creme fraiche ice cream or
simply by themselves
perfect
my next dish is an irresistible take on
a latin american classic
beef empanadas
first finely chop onion and garlic
sweat in a pan of hot olive oil until
tender
add paprika
cinnamon
and cumin
and stir
cooking the spices off intensifies the
flavor
add beef mince to the pan
brown
and season
add chili flakes for a fiery kick
next dried oregano
chopped green olives
and chopped boiled eggs
once it's mixed through set aside to
cool
for the empanada cases roll out puff
pastry this stuff's so time consuming to
make at home so do what i do cheat and
use shop bought
cut into disks
spoon the mixture into one half of the
disk leaving roughly a centimeter border
around the edge
brush the edge of one half of the disc
with egg and fold it over
crimp the edges with your fingers to
seal and remove air pockets
then simply cook in a medium oven until
golden brown
super easy super quick and super tasty
serve a chimichurri a spicy south
american herb salsa
this is what cornish pasties dream of
being when they grow up
my next dish uses super fine filler
pastry and his variation on a moroccan
classic
easy chicken pastilla
first chop onions
ginger then fry them in hot olive oil
add cinnamon
and to give the mix a subtle sweet note
a pinch of sugar
then season chop cook chicken thighs and
add to the mix
pour in chicken stock and then simmer
stir and hold lightly beaten eggs which
thicken the sauce and cook
add in sliced almonds
then set aside to cool
[Music]
now build your pastilla
filo is another pastry that's tricky to
make at home but you can buy fantastic
filo so cheat
brush each sheet with melted butter and
lay four sheets into a greased baking
tin
[Music]
spoon in half of the fantastic aromatic
chicken filling
add four more butter sheets of filo
pastry
and simply pile in the rest of the
delicious chicken
finally cover with a couple of sheets of
filo and fold over all the draped sides
brush with more butter
then bake in a hot oven for 10 to 15
minutes
until the top is crispy and golden brown
you want all the filler paste
wonderfully crunchy and golden
so turn over and return for another 10
minutes
when done removed
and for a different but delicious sweet
finishing touch dust lightly with icing
sugar and cinnamon
intensely aromatic sweet and savory
crispy and succulent an extraordinary
pie that has to be tasted to be believed
[Music]
three types of pastry
three mouthwatering fillings
three more recipes you can stake your
life on
and so simple to do
beautiful
for easy accurate baking you need the
right kit
you don't need to spend a fortune on
masses of kitchen equipment here's my
quick guide to two essentials you need
for baking
scales and a sieve
bacon is so popular now these scales are
absolutely essential especially when you
have to follow the recipe to the exact
grammar these digital scales are so easy
to follow they can convert from pounds
and ounces to kilos and grams and more
importantly so much easier to use than
your mum's old weight absolutely perfect
a sieve make sure you get one with a
long handle and balancing hooks so you
can rest it over your mixing bowl or a
pan easy thing to have in the drawer
costs nothing but it's so effective
especially with bacon
with these two pieces of kit definitely
on the right road to baking like a pro
[Music]
welcome back to my ultimate cookery
course
next on my guide to better bacon
i'll be teaching you how to make a
stylishly simple and sumptuous
cheesecake
peaceful
but first
be it bacon or any type of cooking
always pays off to use the best
ingredients you can find and you're
never too old to learn from the experts
[Music]
next my shopping guide to get the best
milk and cream
when it comes to knowing what makes
great quality milk dairy farmer charlie
ray is your man
he's been producing milk from he's heard
of handmade specialist breed jersey
cattle for over 30 years
[Music]
yeah they're part of the family almost
so he's up to his wellies in the stuff
jersey milk is very high butter fat
which therefore means it is very creamy
very creamy to drink and it's the best
quality milk you'll get anywhere
jersey cows
very docile very friendly very easy to
manage and this is my favorite um
she's about 17 years old she's called
misty
if you think of the large arctic milk
tank as you see going up and down the
motorways she's filled one and a half of
those on her own
[Music]
i reckon these are happy cows they've
got a dry roof over their heads they've
got a dry bed and they've got as much
food as they want
the happier they are and the better kept
they are the better the quality of the
milk that comes out the other end
[Music]
this is what's called an abreast milking
parlour
one down the other way and it suits us
in as much as we've got contact with the
cows we can treat each cow individually
the milk goes up through a meat up into
that line through a big filter and into
the tank
well there you are
without this product you wouldn't have
chocolate cheese yogurts it's the base
ingredient in so many things that you
buy and totally take for granted
and where there's milk there's also
glorious cream essential for brilliant
bacon and lots of savory dishes too
[Music]
single cream is around 18 fat so it's a
lighter option for topping desserts or
stirring into savory sauces whereas
double cream at nearly 50 fat is lovely
and rich in panna cottas or in a
carbonara source as well as being able
to withstand boiling whipping and
freezing
sour cream salad with a similar culture
to that used in yogurt is a really tasty
topping for chilies or baked potatoes
clotted cream rich thick and a delicious
indulgence served with puddings and
scones or an ice cream to make it extra
rich
and mascarpone actually a creamy soft
italian cheese famously used in italian
dessert tiramisu it's also fantastic in
cheesecakes
[Music]
it is font of all life
in great bacon as with all cooking
sometimes less is more
the easiest dishes look and taste
spectacular when they're done well
and it doesn't come any simpler or more
stylish than my next dish wonderful
baked cheesecake for me food always has
to be impressive but when it comes to
desserts
often you see spun sugar or wild
decorations remember simple
is always the most impressive this
cheesecake is so straightforward yet so
delicious
now
cream cheese leave it out the fridge for
five or ten minutes go nice and soft
trust me your arms will be thanking you
sugar in this cheesecake is the new york
cheesecake because it's baked so there's
no base start creaming the cheese and
the sugar
spending the amount of time i do in the
states if there's one thing they know
how to do out there is the most amazing
impressive cheesecake rich delicious but
so simple
work the bowl
lift the ball to your advantage
really whisk
whisk whisk whisk
lovely
nice and creamy now
get your eggs
add the extra mixture bit by bit doing
it this way it's more efficient
hey you're incorporating a lot of air
b the mixture doesn't separate
lastly your egg
lovely
of course you can use electric mixer but
why go to the gym we can just make a
cheesecake a day
a cheesecake a day
keep the bingo wings away
now a couple of tablespoons of flour
give it a whisk
stop something going lumpy
now i want to scent that cheesecake
i've got the freshness zest of the lemon
in there i want to sort of tart it up
even more fold in
some fresh raspberries
so just mix them through
be careful to crush them
then grease the cake in with butter this
will ensure your cheesecake slides out
beautifully
get your mix
let that fall in
now take your cake tin and just
tap it
mixture hits the bottom of the cake tin
the raspberries rise and you've got
raspberries at the top the middle and
the bottom it also stops all these
little pockets of air trapping
underneath the mixture in the cake tin
there's no holes
in the cheesecake now into the oven 180
degrees for 35 to 40 minutes
[Music]
slightly souffled up
pull off
[Music]
that's the color i wanted
on top
and look at it
it's one of the simplest
yet the most stylish cheesecakes
anywhere beautiful
[Music]
next my tricks to the trade and kitchen
tips
kicking off with how to handle pastry
lightly flour the surface
pastry on top
rolling pin now the secret now
is don't overwork the pastry firm push
turn the pastry round and this helps to
even the pastry
turn
and roll
now as it starts to crack
don't worry just by pushing it back
together it sort of unites the pastry
immediately apply pressure turn the
pastry now the average thickness is down
to a one pound coin
back on to the rolling pin
and look
beautiful
for the neatest edge on tarts and
quiches my tip is to let the pastry hang
over the side of the tin when you bake
it trim around the edge once the pastry
is cooked it will give you a cleaner
edge and prevent it from shrinking
[Music]
my tip for even rising is to place cakes
and tarts in the center of the oven so
the air can circulate all the way around
them
to test your cake to make sure it's done
insert a knife skewer or even a piece of
spaghetti in the center if there's
mixture stuck to it it's not done yet
if it comes out clean your cake's ready
[Music]
if you don't have any baking beans to
hand for blind baking you can use any
rice grain or pulse
you won't be able to cook with them
afterwards but do keep them to reuse
them next time
when you're folding egg whites or
whipped cream into cake mixtures you
want to retain as much air in the
mixture as you can
my tip use a metal spoon as the sharp
thin edge will keep more of the air in
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stake your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef many of
these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the app store for
details go on get cooking